hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so i just arrived in croatia today as
you can see guys
i am on a boat all right i'm on a boat
here
so i'm going to sleep in this beautiful
and peaceful
place tonight there is not too much wind
which is
good and as promised guys i'm here to
make an update on amc
because we had some strong bearish moves
that happened the past two days
and i'm here to analyze everything that
happened with you and tell you what i'm
seeing coming
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so a lot of things happen
on friday and i
as usual i'm gonna first start by
remembering
you what i was telling you guys in my
last video
this was my drawing and i have to say
that on this one guys i'm very sorry i
didn't see it coming we had
two very bearish days in a row so
thursday
and friday session i did i did my last
video
here around 57 and i told you guys that
61.64
is the level we need to trade above so
that my
scenario is confirmed but here what
happened is that basically
the market got here rejected at 61 as
you can see
and then strongly moved down all right
and we went
to 48 so i'm gonna come to this i'm
gonna tell you
what i think might happen next i'm gonna
tell you again what is my new
uh what are my new scenarios but first
very interesting
i want to go through what happened here
with you and i want to see if
i could have have seen it coming and
once again guys you need to be aware
that my scenarios they're just scenarios
you know so most of the time i'm right
that's true but sometimes i'm gonna be
wrong like here
so you always need to be prepared for
kind of the worst case scenario and here
let's analyze if we could have seen it
coming so basically
my scenario was like this we do one two
and i
thought we were in a three and here you
know what i use
to know if the market is going to shift
from the trend it's it's having from my
scenario is for example
divergences so here i measure the high
here and the high here and i check the
macd during the same time
and basically guys here i have no
information all right the market is
making a flat but the macd is going
higher so it's not even an exaggerated
divergence all right
we could have have you know this one so
the bearish exaggerated divergence which
is here
so basically the market making it flat
you know same highs
and the macd going lower but we didn't
even have it
all right you can see that the macd was
not going lower the market was going
higher
which is not bearish so here there was
nothing bearish the only thing that you
could have used
and once again guys i'm sorry i was not
with you during
those two days as you know i quit my job
so i'm gonna have more time i'm gonna
follow amc more closely with you
and here you had one information that is
very useful guys
trend lines all right so basically i
told you 52 is a level but you have a
short term level here when you connect
this slow
and you go through this one and you try
to connect as many lows as you can
you have this trend line here and you
can see that it got broken here and then
we started to strongly move down
so this one is not easy to spot you need
to be a day trader you need to be
uh you know 100 focused on your market
uh which i wasn't guys because i'm on
holidays so i didn't
warn you here and once again i'm very
sorry about that i will try really my
best for this not to happen again
you know it's training it happens
sometimes you have some unexpected
moves uh that you try to analyze
afterwards you try to see what you could
have done to
see it coming here the only thing that i
would have done is to use this trendline
and once it's broken you can see we had
one two
three six reactions guys and then it's
broken and then we only move
lower then let me come back to what to
me is happening right now so
this scenario is definitely of the of
the table but we still
have maybe this one all right so this
could be a stronger abc
so this is one of my scenarios it's not
my preferred scenario
so basically it's an xyz you can see
that here you have some small abcs
you see a b a
b c a
b c and
abc so it's you know the usual stuff you
know a combination of corrective
patterns all right
so this one was not easy to spot but
this is what
could still be happening and to know
that this
is still a kind of you know consistent
one two i measure so let me get rid of
those small abcs you know because
they're just polluting my
my chart here but i'm just gonna keep
the bigger one and here you can measure
basically you use fibs guys as i showed
you how to do
my little boat is just you know swimming
down the boat so
it's a bit disturbing me so let's stay
focused here
all right so i measured the first wave
and you can see guys
that the second wave went to the 61.8
percent
so the basically 48 level and guys this
is the level
i told you about all right so i'm not
saying that i saw this one coming this
you know
strong bearish move that happened in
past two days i didn't see him coming
that's true but
the level we went to is for me still a
level that is acceptable
in my scenario that this is still a
force that is
finished complete and here we're having
a one two
but this second wave is a bit long for
me so this is not my preferred scenario
but this is still on the table we are
trading above 48
we closed the week just above 52 guys
which is actually the level that for me
was very important we closed above this
level
and you can see that on the four hours
time frame here we
closed at 52.7 guys which is above this
trend line which is good so basically
here if you use 52 on the four hours
guys you don't even have a breakout you
have
first the breakout but then we didn't
confirm we didn't have two consecutive
candles trading below 52.
so guys this is for me quite okay and
i'm gonna come to my scenario that is
actually this one and one more thing i
wanted to show you guys is that here
actually on the first time frame look
what we're having once again
you can see that from here to here the
market is making higher
lows right higher lows what is the
magnet doing guys
what is the magnet doing lower lows
what's that
it's a hidden bullish divergence let me
show you guys this
it's this one the market making higher
lows
even when the momentum is going down
which means that we are
in a bearish movement and that the bears
are not able to make
new lows which is bullish on the forward
time frame
which is the reason why i'm coming back
to my scenario is that
bears and control i just said the
momentum is shifting down so you know
when the momentum is shifting down it's
actually
hard to really start the new move so
my scenario that was here that this is a
one two
is maybe not the one that is playing out
because
i would have liked to see a shift of
momentum coming earlier
i didn't have it so right now i think
that maybe we're doing a triangle an
a b c d e so i'm not sure but this is my
preferred scenario so we bounce back we
go to 57
we do the d wave then we're coming back
again to the 52 level one more time
before the strong move up so basically
i'm still bullish on the long term
i am neutral on the short medium term i
am very careful on this 48 level guys if
we break this 48 level on the first time
frame
this means that basically this scenario
is off the table
and that this is my alternative scenario
and you need to be aware that this is
a possible scenario guys it means that
basically
we're having a big abc guys a wxy let's
label it like this
which would be like w x y all right and
then we would probably go back to the 37
level around here before bouncing back
so
anyways in all of my scenarios we are in
a false wave
if this changes i will let you know but
for now
i have all the kind of behaviors of a
force wave
i just struggle a bit to label it
properly and to
predict what the market would do that's
true corrective waves are usually messy
and here i'm struggling a bit
once again i am very sorry i didn't warn
you about this
strong bearish moves that happened the
past two days but right now i think that
the situation is under control i think
that
this force wave is a triangle so let's
see let's see if i'm right if
it may not be a triangle as well it may
also be a zigzag
or a flat that would look but this would
be like the second wave that would look
like this but we could also have
you know a wxy correction like this so
careful at the 48 level
on the first time frame guys this is the
level you want to watch the 52 level
is still a support level so you can have
a look at this one as well
and one more thing i wanted to talk
about guys in this video
is a friend of mine that is actually
living in hong kong he is a billionaire
very young billionaire he just created
his cryptocurrency and he is giving me
the opportunity guys to tell you about
that and basically you just sign up and
you get
free token of his cryptocurrency that he
just started five weeks ago that is not
listed yet
so this is a golden opportunity and it's
a referral system so basically if some
people sign up and give your name
you're gonna have free token that are
coming on your account
and then it's gonna get listed probably
in six months or something like this
and we're gonna see how much this is
worth so for now
maybe it's not gonna worth much but i
believe he put like millions of usd
in this project so i believe this is
gonna go you know it can
be a very nice project it's basically
about decentralized finance it's
something that is
actually very promising uh in the
current environment
so i'm gonna give you this in the
description i'm gonna talk about this in
my discord as well
so just a small thing i wanted to tell
you guys in this video
and i hope you enjoyed everything i told
you here i am still bullish on amc on
the long term i am neutral in the short
term but i believe we're gonna have this
fifth wave coming
maybe a bit later maybe in like two
weeks you know something like this we
need maybe a bit more time maybe
around the 15th of july something like
this you know once once this triangle
would have converged fully
so that's it for me and i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget guys to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys